well etsy is a very popular website for
custom crafts but if you try to use it
today there might be a problem thousands
of shops are on strike john langler
explains why
[Music]
the issue comes from fees etsy made a
marginal increase to what it charges
creators to use the site for thousands
of etsy sellers it's more proof they say
they're not being supported you know
when you list your product for one thing
and you're getting so much less for it
then you should it's just kind of hard
to want to list on etsy ashley bilbro is
new to etsy but may stop selling her
clay earrings the online marketplace
requires sellers to pay a fee per
listing in february etsy reported an
all-time high for sales and revenue but
starting today etsy rates are hiking
from 5 to 6.5 percent it doesn't sound
like a lot until you're selling more and
more and it's like you're not making as
much as you should for a product etsy
says the change comes directly from
seller feedback they're not upset they
say about the fee increase because it'll
benefit them the company says it will
invest the extra money in marketing
technology and customer support an etsy
spokesperson says our seller's success
is a top priority we're committed to
providing great value so they're able to
grow their business but ashley and more
than 5 000 other etsy sellers don't feel
supported there's a long list of like
ways that etsy isn't like helping the
creators on the platform
that you know they would really like to
change as sellers
starting today they're protesting the
price hike by putting their shops on
vacation mode and halting sales of their
products they're also asking shoppers to
stop buying on the site until april 18th
as for ashley she isn't letting this get
in the way of expanding her business for
homemade goods like that's the place
everyone goes so it's like a hard like
if you don't go back to etsy where do
you go she wants to sell more of her
earrings at craft fairs and on her own
site
then there are no fees at all
john langler live local now